I think the biggest opportunity is going
to be how societies care for each other
I think it's been very fragmented in the
past and I think when you look at what's
happening across the world this moment
in time societies need to get back to
caring for each other some people
talking about bringing back as the
nuclear family extended family but when
I look back to my grandmother and I look
back to my family in the past how we
looked after each other how the neighbor
support each other and communities cared
for each other and I think the biggest
opportunities to let's get back to our
grass roots from their point of a
maternal child in women's health and the
women in general we know that sadly
every two seconds the in some way in the
world the woman dies in the process of
giving birth or a thought of giving
birth and giving birth is supposed to be
a very joyous period in time for the
family for the community but often in
something released it's actually a very
sad occasion so for me I think that the
access universal access to health care
is a what we should be working towards
in the next in the next 10 years
focusing largely on the empowerment of
women and also ensuring that women get
the best possible a access tool to
health care I think it would be
transparent leadership among the
politicians in the continent of Africa
Africa as a whole is an underdeveloped
country or continent and we can only
forge ahead in our development if our
leadership gets up stands up become
transparent and do things which would
see to the development of the continent